Hello and welcome to
Microbiology Hemorrhagic
Viral Infections. My
name is Lettis Lehmann
and I'm both your micro
and immunology teacher.
These are the learning
objectives. When students
finish this lecture, you
should be able to describe
the characteristics
of viruses that cause
hemorrhagic fever, compare
and contrast viral families
involved in hemorrhagic
fever infections, identify
disease manifestations
caused by these infections,
and summarize the
epidemiology transmission,
pathogenesis, clinical
features, diagnosis,
management, and prevention
of these same diseases.
All the hemorrhagic fever
viruses predominantly come
from four vital families,
the arena viridae, the bonia
viridae, the filoviridae,
and the flaviviridae. Most
of these diseases end up
being a multi-system diseases
that involve multiple
organs of course they affect
the vascular system at one
point or the other with
some destruction which results
to hemorrhage hence they
get the hemorrhagic fever
and sometimes symptoms
depending on the virus can
range from pretty mild to
extremely severe to life
-threatening and lethal here
you can see this is probably
a picture of Ebola virus.
There are some commonalities
for a lot of these
viruses, so it's important
to remember them.
A lot of them are single
-stranded. They have
a single-stranded RNA
genome and usually have
enveloped viruses,
so they'll have the
capsid and the envelope
on the outside.
uh there are most of the
natural reservoir is usually
animals humans are not the
typical natural reservoir
and of course we're usually
accidental hosts too so you
can definitely describe again
these um these particular
diseases as zoonotic and
they can also involve some
vectors some vectors may
be able to transmit those
diseases like for example
if you look on the side here
we have dengue fever,
yellow virus, sorry yellow
fever virus, not all ones
that require a mosquito
as a vector. So the
rest of this table shows
you the different
viral families, the
arena virida, the bonia
virida, the main virus
among them, Lassa and
Hanta for example,
and then the disease
they cause as well as
the reservoir and we'll
go through each one
of them as we get through
the slides but this
is kind of a good table
to have initially.
This table highlights the
main viruses we're going
to talk about again the
arena virus family which
is which the most
representative of is the Lassa
virus which caused Lassa
fever but as you can see
there's other type of viruses
like Janine, Matupo virus
and so on. These usually
have different types of
hemorrhagic fevers whether
depending on the country
they're looking at. So
like the Janine virus is
in Argentine, the Matupo
is Bolivian and so forth.
And then like the Bunia
viruses, Henta
virus is the main
virus in the Bunia which
causes Henta virus pulmonary
syndrome. But there's
also the Fabi fever virus
and nairovirus which
causes Caribbean and Congo
hemorrhagic fever. The
flaviviruses includes dengue and
yellow fever and philoviruses
include Ebola and Marburg
which cause Ebola,
hemorrhagic fever and Marburg.
The arena viridae characterized
by the Lassa virus
again like most of these
are enveloped negative
single-stranded RNA. They
have a segmented genome
and they're also spherical
shape rodents are
natural reservoir and
again they get transmitted
from these rodents it
could be either from the
contaminated feces or urine
and you can catch them
from either inhalation or
direct contact with those
****** fluids or or
sometimes person to person
by coming in contact with
the blood or excretion
of that person that's
contaminated incubation
period usually between
10 to 14 days those those
the virus that affects
macrophages causes
interferon to be released
which and a lot of it which
causes cell and vascular
damage and hence the
hemorrhagic aspect of
it a lot of the you know
immunopathological events
that happen here are
would result in further
tissue destruction and
these are the viruses that
are part of this group
and the previous
slides we talked about
which countries
they even come from
this is the Lassa virus
here shown by electron
microscopy showing
that spherical virus
and here is the like
a macrophage with the
inclusion bodies caused
by the virus inside of it
And here is the rodents
that transmitted,
what's referred to as
the multi mammoth rat.
Most locations,
West Africa, Guinea,
Nigeria, Liberia, Sierra Leone.
Most of the Lhasa virus
cases are mild, I would say
80%, because of course
some of them can be very
severe. Here is a list of
the clinical symptoms, fever,
headache, muscle ache,
malaise, sore throat, cough,
so pretty much now almost
looks like flu, chest
pain, abdominal, but then
the hemorrhage of course,
and if it gets very severe,
organ failure and shock.
Diagnosis is due to either
by a lyxam or RT-PCR,
which is of course a
type of nucleic acid
amplification and
therapy is in the form of
revivirin the antiviral
and of course supportive
most common
complication from lassa
if a person
recovers is deafness
usually like a
third of the cases
have some degree
of hearing loss
demonia viruses or debonia
viridae which includes
antivirus and drift valley
virus and niori virus are also
enveloped spherical negative
single-stranded segmented
genome again remember the
negative here it's either
negative sense or a
positive sense these guys
are negative again transmission
typically arthropods
mosquitoes ticks flies
or in the case of henta
it's usually aerosols from
the from the rodent feces
initially you get viremia,
and it just looks like
flu-like, and then it
develops secondary, where
the virus ends up in
deeper tissues, and it can
cause, go anywhere to the
brain, cause encephalitis,
liver, cause
necrosis, or end up
being hemorrhagic in
blood, and it can go from
something more lighter,
simpler, to something
way more severe,
and the virus, pulmonary
syndrome, which
is the variation
of the virus that is inhaled is
typically a very
serious disease
here it shows the picture
the antivirus and the
electron microscopy and
it's kind of a cycle of
where antivirus typically
happens and usually the
the rodents that transmit
it is the white-footed
mouse you can see the
white feet right here and
from there like urine
droppings etc and these
are common mice the issue
becomes is if there's a
cycle of rain and dryness
so the rain allows the
the virus and the moisture
to grow better and
then the dryness allows
them to aerosolize
so it's a combination
of these cycles which
permits the organism to
become more aerosol and
usually transmits
the or increase the
incidence let's say
of the infection
antivirus was initially
discovered in this region
here referred to as the
four corners because it
was a kind of a quarter
region here between the
four state utah colorado
arizona and new mexico
and the climate there is
kind of natural to allowing
the virus to uh to to
spread and this is where
a lot of the cases occur
but as you can see um
and this you know
antivirus was discovered i
would say in the sometime
in the 80s since then the
disease has been spread
to california washington
and and several other
states where can see
cases since we've been
monitoring this and Texas.
Yeah, I mean, this is the
spread of emerging infectious
disease like this one.
Initially, this virus,
because they didn't know
what was causing it, they
called it the Senombre
virus, which means the
unknown virus, but now we know
it's Hentavirus. And local
people that lived in this
region, which was primarily
Native Americans of
the Navajo Nation. They
knew about this virus for
generation and generation
generations and before even
you know current western
science learned about it.
Antivirus illness usually
has an incubation period
of one to two weeks.
Initially a fever, chills,
headache, nausea,
abdominal pain, back pain,
redness, eye redness and
then blurred vision and
it can progress to
hypotension, acute shock,
vascular leakage, and
even acute kidney failure.
So this is where
it's characterized as
hemorrhagic fever
or renal syndrome.
And this typically can
lead to the conjunctival
hemorrhage, like
you see right here,
the bloodshot eyes. And a
lot of times this is the
picture you see in a lot
of the movies, like the
zombie movies showing people
basically with viruses
that they look like that.
That's usually where they
got it from. So treatment
is mainly supportive.
Prognosis varies on the
different serotype of
antivirus with a mortality
rate ranging from
kind of low 1% to a 15%,
which is kind of high.
Again, the most prevention
happens controlling
the rodent population that
that white foot mouse,
you know, avoid disturbing,
rodent urine, dropping, saliva,
their material if
they're in the backyard
or the garage or
something like that.
The Flavik Viridae is
the family that includes
important viral diseases
like dengue fever virus and
yellow fever virus, also
St. Louis encephalitis,
West Nile, Zika, and even
hepatitis C. Many of these
viruses you can see here,
dengue, yellow fever, St.
Louis, Nile is now all named
after locations. And that's
not typical of how we name
viruses. So transmission
usually from a mosquito,
female mosquito infected with
the vertebrate host and
pass it to human. They're
enveloped positive sense,
single-stranded RNA viruses.
This is a figure that shows
kind of the development
of the pathogenesis of
the virus and of the
Flaviviridae and how they
progress two to three days
into the disease. You
can get either mild or
asymptomatic presentation.
In that case, the, you
know, the vectors introducing
the virus into the
body. You get a prodrome
piremium and then resulting
in initially like a mild
systemic disease that
can involve, you know,
acrophages, liver, spleen,
and little fever,
aches, chills,
and even the
vascular endothenium,
and then it can progress to,
after a week,
severe or life-threatening
presentation with
hepatitis, encephalitis,
hemorrhagic liver.
So, let's talk about dengue
fever transmitted by the
Aedes aegypti mosquito,
which is actually a mosquito
that can transmit several
other diseases we'll discuss.
Right here you can see
the viral particles of the
electron microscopy shown
inside endothelial cells.
It's spread in the
Southwest Asia,
Western Pacific, Latin and
Africa, but at least this
is initially where most of the
virus is. but this geography
has been changing and
spreading so and this is
considered an emerging viral
disease and as you can see
from this map and this is
not a very recent map showing
it's almost ten years ago
showing the different areas
where dengue fever
has now been isolated.
So definitely it's
going beyond the areas
of South America and
Africa and to start
to spread to, you know,
like you see here,
like Florida, for
example, there's been more
cases and more and more
cases of dengue fever.
In the previous slide,
we saw those cases in
the world in different
locations. What I
want to show you here
is two different maps.
One of them is in 2022, just
to kind of make a point.
And this one is in 2025,
both basically from the
center of disease control.
But what I want you to look
at is how many places we
were able to identify the
virus in 2022 versus how
many now it's spreading.
And basically three years.
So again, I would say
in the years 2000, you
would never hear a case and
not even in Florida, maybe
there was like one or
two. And if you talk about
dengue, nobody had no idea.
But now we can see lots
of cases in Florida, lots
of cases in Texas, lots
of cases in California,
even the Northeast, and now
it's starting to spread.
This is very unfortunate
because this is a
really, really a disease
with a huge burden,
both globally and nationwide.
The incubation period of dengue
fever is usually
four to seven days.
Fever, headache, rash,
muscle pain, and then
what's referred to as
break bone fever. That's
probably the worst part
of this disease. When
you talk to patients,
they always say that they
feel like their bones
are breaking. That's very
painful. Also, you can
have thrombocytopenia,
retroorbital pain, and
you have a septic shock.
And then it can go from
dengue, basically fever, to
dengue or dengue disease
into what's referred to as
dengue hemorrhagic fever
so that these actually
have two forms the more
milder dengue disease and the
more severe dengue hemorrhagic
fever again this is
a very deadly complication
of actual dengue fever
the fever is extremely high
usually there's a lot of
hemorrhage included which
happens from the both
like *********** of the
liver and embolment of the
liver. In severe cases you
can get circuitry failure,
very serious in children,
usually bleeding occurs
three to five days after the
fever and has very similar
presentation through to
chingkongonia infection.
So and you know a lot
of times in locations
it's the diseases
are endemic at both.
And here's shown the
rash and the hemorrhagic
display of dengue
hemorrhagic fever.
Diagnosis is typically done
by nucleic acid amplification,
mainly reverse
transcriptase PCR
treatment so far is
mainly supportive.
There are four major
serotypes of dengue virus.
And if you get infected
with one, you get
immunity for that one.
The problem is infection
with one can confirm
immunity to another
stereotype, but it can
also, in small cases,
cause an antibody-dependent
cytotoxicity. And so if
you get exposure and get
exposed again, you get a worse
version of the disease.
So that's kind of an
interesting complication,
so to speak, and also makes
vaccination a difficult problem.
proposition so to speak.
Lots of cases of dengue
fever worldwide, almost
50 million cases and
that includes that break
bone symptom that we talked
about but then there's
a lesser, a much lesser
number of people that
actually developed
a more severe dengue
hemorrhagic fever with
almost approximately 400,000.
Next is yellow fever
virus, again part
of the Flaviviridae
family, predominantly
endemic in South America
and Africa now, it used to
be worldwide, but because of
mosquito control got better.
It's transmitted by the
same mosquito that transmits
tingi, Aedes aegypti, and
you can acquire it either
from an urban setting or
from a jungle setting, which
is referred to as sylvatic
from the jungle. Usually
monkeys are the ones that
spread disease, mosquitoes
of course are the vectors,
and travels from these rural
areas can introduce the
virus into the urban areas
and then and then the mosquito
carries it from there.
This map shows the map of
South America and Africa
and showing of course where
the countries and regions
that have yellow fever is
common where vaccination is
recommended and where could
be for example current
outbreaks of um you know of
like yellow fever so again
these are the endemic areas
predominantly where we
have um yellow fever consistent
cases always coming up
here are the clinical
features or symptoms of yellow
fever you know red eyes
headache bleeding jaundice
muscle aches hepatomegaly
back pain even and
vomiting so it's kind of a
really all over the place
when it comes to symptoms
diagnosis you know for
this viral infection is
usually done by either
ELISA or PCR and they both
work very well and you can
also do a liver biopsy
and look for what's called
councilman's bodies which
are you can see them
right here where the arrow
is on this liver biopsy
and basically it's these
are like eosinophilic uh,
hepoptotic globules
that show up
as a result of, uh, the virus.
Um,
treatment is pretty much
supportive. Uh, thankfully
most people recover
within a week and there's
also a vaccine, but only
given in areas that have
active, uh, obviously you
don't need to take the
vaccine. If you're not in
an area that is exposed
to the, the virus for
the vaccines are live
attenuated. So it's a weakened
version of the virus. And
so it can obviously,
with all live attenuated
vaccine you cannot give
them to infants less than
six months of age, pregnant
women or anybody who's
immunocompromised. Next
we're going to discuss the
filoviridae family which
also envelope negative single
-stranded RNA viruses that
have a linear RNA genome.
These viruses are capable
of replicating in multiple
cell types as you can
see here, endothelial
cells, monocytes and
macrophages, dendritic cells, a
lot of our antigen presenting
cells, so to speak,
in a lot of the reticular
endothelial system,
pretty much. Hence
the damage they do and
why the involvement of
hemorrhagic symptoms.
Transmission is typically
by the African least
fruit bat. That's what
most people suspect these
viruses are transmitted by,
and of course also primates,
other primates besides
humans oh and humans can
of course transmit it
once you come contact with
their with the ******
fluids and the two viruses
under this family is
ebola and marburg probably
one of the worst of of
all the hemorrhagic fever
viruses on top here shows
um this shows ebola virus
and you know long
filamentous like that uh
look of it and then this
is marburg down here
Just like to reiterate
some of the previous
ones, of course, the
genome of the viruses,
but mainly where they come
from, which is Central
Africa, as you can see
right here in this cluster.
First recorded ever case
of Marburg was in 1967.
It was actually detected
in Marburg, Germany, from
monkeys that were brought in
from Africa during research.
and the first case of Ebola
was detected in 1976 and
since then we've had
intermittent outbreaks of these
viruses almost consistently
again as we talked about
transmitted by food bats and
primates and also you can
catch it from direct contact
especially with infected
blood other body flow but
also fomites the viruses
can stay in the environment
for an extended period of
time. This slide shows
a flowchart of how
the viruses enter the
body and already replicate
like we talked about.
They pretty much
target the endo-reticular
endothelial system,
of course monocytes,
macrophages, even dendritic
cells triggering a lot
of cytokines resulting
in a cytokine storm
which basically creates
a sepsis-like symptoms
and conditions, a lot
of tissue necrosis and
damage to areas of the
blood liver spleen
multiple organ involvement
of course these damaged
endothelial cells causes
problems like adhesion
proteins we end up with cell
lysis and you know vascular
leakage when you when you're
damaged endothelial lining
that's the bottom line
what happens blood leaks
into different cavities can
result in of course edema,
hypovolemic shock and
even disseminated intervascular
coagulation which is
widespread clotting in
different parts of the body.
Symptoms of both Ebola
Marburg are sudden. Initially
they look like flu with
fever weakness fatigue but
then they've progressed
abdominal pain, nausea, vomiting,
diarrhea and muscle pain
and also end up with
conjunctival hemorrhage which
shows that bloodshot look and
of course symptoms can start
increasing severity and
the progression is pretty
quick usually one to three
days end up with delirium
liver failure like the ic
diffused hemorrhage and
shock and followed by death
both are diagnosed with
reverse transcriptase
pcr so nucleic acid
nucleic acid amplification
treatment so far it's mainly
supportive i think there's
an antibody that's what
developed for ebola that
might be my work um these
are the fatality cases really
high with ebola depending
on the strain because
there's different strains
of ebola there's zaire ebola
zaire ebola saddam ebola
restin and ebola ivory coast
and so depending on which
one um you get different
levels of fatality but it's
all pretty high 50 to 90
% extremely high Marburg you
know quarter of the case
is also very high again
like we said these are some
of the worst pathogens
really known to mankind Zaire
is one of the worst and
the strains of Ebola and
there's actually now a vaccine
for it so thankfully that
could be prevent spreading
of the disease or at least
protect populations that
are vulnerable for that.
And of course, it's
called Ebola Zaire
because that's where
the strain was isolated
in Zaire, the country
of Zaire in Africa.
So here's the vaccine,
Ebola virus, the R-V
-O-E-B, seems to be
very effective for that
particular strain but
doesn't have a lot of
cross protection because
these viruses can can
differ significantly
almost by 40 percent.
We had the first case
unfortunately of Ebola in the
United States in 2014.
You can think in the notes
section of the slide there's
a link to the article that
talks about them and bottom
line there was a person
that hopped in the plane
from West Africa and ended
up States, but they showed
up with symptoms in Texas.
Healthcare workers like
a nurse, so forth, who
treated them, contacted
and caught Ebola. And there
was a few cases, I would
say, maybe like two or
three or four max, but it
was pretty alarming that
a disease can travel so
quickly around the world
and end up right at your
doorstep, so to speak.
So this really brings
this to the forefront.
This is just a board-style
practice question for
you guys that you can go
through and answer it based
on the information that
we have in the PowerPoint.